[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
el Primer Ministro de Camboya ordenó
cerrar uno de los pocos medios
independientes que quedan en el país
justificando que la estación de radio La
Voz de la democracia calumnió a su hijo
para los defensores de la libertad de
expresión es un hecho que enciende las
alarmas
en India sigue indignando la práctica de
ofrecer niñas a una diosa para luego ser
usadas como esclavas sexuales menores de
10 años son obligadas a entregar su
virginidad a cambio de bienes o dinero
aunque esto ha sido prohibido durante
décadas esta práctica se sigue
presentando en la actualidad
podrán los robots reemplazar a los seres
humanos esa es una pregunta que ha
venido cobrando relevancia en los
últimos años gracias a los agigantados
avances de la tecnología Japón es un
país pionero en esta industria y en esta
edición veremos cuán exitosos son estos
proyectos en lugares como los
restaurantes
iniciamos este recorrido por el
continente asiático en Camboya porque el
Primer Ministro junseng ordenó el cierre
de uno de los pocos medios de
comunicación locales independientes que
quedan en el país por publicar un
artículo que según él calumniaba a su
hijo el llamado hombre fuerte de Camboya
ha tomado medidas cada vez más severas
contra cualquier oposición
la orden llegó de la noche a la mañana y
de arriba la voz de la Democracia de
Camboya también conocida como Bot
tendría que dejar de publicar y
transmitir a las 10 de la mañana
no me esperaba esto el Primer Ministro
hizo que esto sucediera
es como cerrar las voces de la gente una
de las últimas estaciones de radio y
sitios web independientes de Camboya Bot
era conocido por informar extensamente
sobre temas delicados
esperemos que este no sea el final de
todo aún así que haremos nuestro mejor
esfuerzo ojalá se pueda encontrar una
solución pronto
Pero habiendo atraído la ira del líder
del país antes de las elecciones
generales de Julio Su futuro no parece
prometedor
acusó a voz de calumniar a su hijo
hunmanet Quién es el jefe del ejército y
heredero aparente de su padre el
artículo de Bot decía que humanet había
firmado un documento en nombre de su
padre autorizando una donación de
$100,000 en ayuda por el terremoto en
Turquía el Primer Ministro dijo que el
artículo tergiversaba los hechos porque
solo él tenía la autoridad para tomar
decisiones sobre la ayuda exterior la
decisión es particularmente preocupante
debido al impacto escalofriante que
tendrá sobre la libertad de expresión y
el acceso a la información antes de las
elecciones nacionales de Julio
nuevamente para una especie de barrido
limpio para un giro a su hijo un manet
como el futuro líder y no quiere que
nadie diga nada que sea ni remotamente
crítico con él o su administración
entonces
cuestión de tiempo creo que de alguna
manera antes de que Bot fuera golpeado
nos han golpeado por una acusación
absolutamente ridícula
al nuevo gobierno de Camboya en 1979 se
convirtió en Primer Ministro seis años
después ya gobernado Camboya con mano de
hierro desde entonces antes de las
últimas elecciones generales en 2018
hizo cerrar el Camboya Daily acusando la
publicación de grabación fiscal en los
últimos dos años también ha tomado
medidas enérgicas contra cualquier
oposición condenar a sus oponentes por
cargos sin fundamento
lo que ha sucedido Es que la comunidad
internacional ha perdido un paso se
distrajo un poco perdió la oportunidad
de opinar sobre Camboya quiero decir lo
que ha estado sucediendo en los últimos
dos años es que hunseng ha celebrado
juicios masivos juicios políticos
masivos para ir tras sus oponentes
los ataques antidemocráticos
devalentonado mientras se acerca al
presidente de China
en una declaración conjunta después de
una reunión bilateral Camboya y China
enfatizaron su apoyo mutuo y sus
intereses compartidos además de su firme
oposición a cualquier injerencia
extranjera Nos dirigimos a India donde a
pesar de muchos llamados de
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos sigue
la práctica de un tipo de esclavitud
sexual niñas que cuando tienen su
primera menstruación son ofrecidas a una
diosa para luego satisfacer los deseos
sexuales de hombres Esta es la historia
cuando eran niñas Estas mujeres tenían
sus vidas dedicadas a la diosa India
yeya
se convirtieron en lo que se conoce como
de badasis o sirvientas de la deidad
niñas de tan solo diez años son casadas
con la Diosa y usadas con esclavas
sexuales para hombres
después de que nos hacen de badasis y
después de llegar a la pubertad nos
dicen que ya estamos casadas y que un
hombre quiere nuestra virginidad en
muchos casos como fue el mío mi propio
tío hizo este ritual y me quitó la
virginidad
en la cima de una colina en la pequeña
ciudad de ti en el estado de carnataca
en el sur de India se encuentra un
templo dedicado a la diosa
no se les permite casarse con un mortal
en su lugar son obligadas a entregar su
virginidad a un hombre mayor cuando
tienen su primera menstruación
Generalmente a cambio de dinero o bienes
aunque también para procrear y
transmitir el rango de debadasis a sus
descendientes esta práctica es una forma
para que las familias afectadas por la
pobreza de las castas inferiores se
deshagan de la responsabilidad de sus
hijas consideradas a menudo como una
carga económica algunos creen que su
suerte cambiará o que pueden curarse de
una enfermedad si entregan sus hijas a
la diosa
Es simplemente una tradición ciega que
en el nombre de Dios arruinado nuestras
vidas
si caballo date dirige una ong que ayuda
adapsis ella fue una a través de cantos
tradicionales y sesiones de
sensibilización en escuelas y pueblos
espera poner fin a esta tradición la
práctica ha sido prohibida durante
décadas y los activistas dicen que los
números han disminuido pero las niñas
aún Son dedicadas en ceremonia secretas
en 1991 mujeres funcionarias del
gobierno nos visitaron y sensibilizaron
organizaron capacitaciones y nos
preguntaron por qué este ritual aún
estaba en práctica solo después puede
encontrar mi camino ahora hemos podido
detener la práctica en este distrito y
ayudar a las mujeres al unirse
colectivamente para ayudarse y apoyarse
mutuamente para que nadie sufra como
nosotras
cuatro décadas después de la prohibición
Estatal todavía hay más de 70.000
carnataca según datos de la comisión de
derechos humanos de la India
Así es Asia y se lo contamos en France
24 Estos son nuestros hechos destacados
que marcan la agenda del continente
Taiwán está reforzando sus lazos
militares con Estados Unidos y otras
naciones amigas para hacer frente al
abro comillas expansionismo autoritario
señaló la presidenta seis a los
legisladores estadounidenses que
estuvieron de visita en la isla Estados
Unidos como la mayoría de los países no
tiene vínculos diplomáticos formales con
Taiwán reclamada por china pero de su
patrocinador internacional y proveedor
de armas más importante lo que significa
una fuente constante de fricciones entre
las relaciones Beijing y Washington
pidió a sus ministros y asesores que
vuelen en clase económica y renuncien a
los vehículos de lujo y sus salarios
como parte de una campaña de austeridad
que le ahorrará al gobierno unos 766
millones de dólares al año el ajuste del
cinturón se produce cuando Island que se
enfrenta a una crisis de balanza de
pagos llega a un acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional para asegurar
fondos por un valor de mil millones de
dólares que han estado pendientes desde
finales del año pasado por cuestiones de
política los ministros aceptaron las
medidas voluntariamente y además todos
los miembros del gabinete entregarán sus
salarios y beneficios y pagarán todas
las facturas de servicios públicos de
sus bolsillos
El Banco Central de Australia
reemplazará El retrato de la Reina
Isabel II en una cara de su billete de 5
dólares australianos con un nuevo diseño
para reflejar y honrar la historia de su
cultura indígena el otro lado seguirá
presentando al parlamento australiano en
septiembre de 2022 Australia aseguró que
la imagen del Rey Carlos no reemplazaría
automáticamente a la Reina Isabel en los
billetes de 5 dólares y que podría ser
reemplazada por figuras australianas
recordemos que tras la muerte de la
reina Isabel II el Rey Carlos III es el
jefe de estado en Australia Nueva
Zelanda y otros 12 reinos de la
mancomunidad de Naciones fuera de Reino
Unido Aunque el papel es en gran parte
ceremonial
en Japón es común que un robot cante o
lleve la comida a la mesa de un
restaurante según la federación
internacional de robótica la producción
y exportación de robots aumentó en el
país desde 2020 y a pesar de automatizar
procesos Aún existen muchos desafíos en
la industria veamos el informe de
nuestra corresponsalusa Medina
la industria robótica vio su auge
durante la pandemia según el Ministerio
de economía comercio e industria de
Japón sus reportes revelan que los
ingresos de las compañías aumentaron tal
es el caso de software robotics la
empresa tiene 500 robots en
establecimientos comerciales en Japón
al principio pensábamos que operar los
restaurantes con robots sería automático
pero no los robots hacen trabajos más
simples como limpiar los platos después
de comer traer bebidas etcétera Eso hace
que el tiempo restante los meseros
puedan ofrecer un mejor servicio a los
clientes hablar con ellos recomendar
platos etcétera
entre abril y junio de 2022 se
produjeron
221.686 robots según la asociación de
robots de Japón esto representa un
incremento de
8.1%, si se compara con el mismo periodo
en 2021
dependiendo de las características de
cada tienda la altura del techo la
condición del piso entre otros se
colocan diferentes tipos de robots o
ganar
lo más difícil es ajustarlo al negocio
es necesario estudiar la tienda
exhaustivamente
la disminución de la fuerza laboral hace
atractivo el uso
los robots no pueden hacer todo tipo de
trabajo así que se programan para servir
comida o quitar los platos lo positivo
es que se maximizan los recursos humanos
para que el trabajador pueda centrarse
en la hospitalidad
la falta de capacidad de análisis y
dificultad para resolver problemas
distintos a los que han sido programados
hace difícil que los robots puedan
reemplazar la mano de obra sin embargo
disminuyen tareas y son una alternativa
para satisfacer la demanda laboral
y para el cierre les dejo este dato de
acuerdo con la Organización Mundial de
la Salud japonés el país con mayor
esperanza de vida en todo el mundo al
tener una media de 84,4 años
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24 punto
com y no olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]